tá muito ruim hoje o meu deus em casa e
quer fazer um experimento com que o time
ainda está aqui do lado e eu vou tentar
observar agora com um microscópio é um
bairro inteiro mas que não vai mudar
nada que falar andar que sejam muito bem
vindos
ela achou melhor eu mostrar de que mais
um vídeo finalmente mais um vídeo de
microscópio e uma vassoura na mão ó ó
ninja ou a minha roupa e teve a ver com
a questão é é muito dona de casa foi só
receber muitos comentários votos que
vocês pedem muito mas muito três vídeos
como evitar o jogador ganhou oito e se
faz sentir em breve está vai ser em
breve como evitar a namorada dois kill
por hunt quando os caças 3 milhões de
inscritos e esse é mais complicado
porque porque eu e katherine não temos
assim tanto tempo juntos e então é
difícil conciliar o trabalho mas assim
que surgir a oportunidade eu vou fazer
este vídeo é óbvio é em outro vídeo que
pedem muito também é para continuar a
minha série de microscópio mas disse que
eu tenha me tarântula nova vocês não
perdem muito por um estrago no
microscópio propostas que estavam de
vê-lo de perto mas hoje eu vou tentar
incomodar um pouco para que ela me 10
eu nunca consegui pegar nela até hoje
então hoje vamos tentar algo muito
arriscado pessoal que observava no
microscópio que eu espero que dê certo
eo soft mostra que nós vamos ver mais
aqui no microscópio mas antes disso há
pessoas muito a equipe que neste vídeo
isso vocês foram destaque no canal do
solo e inscreva-se com toda a força e
atribuiu se nem pra serem todas as
notificações já que a ética feliz
vamos lá então nosso objetivo é que os
vírus com microscópio 10 uma nota de 20
euros é muito dinheiro 20 euros dá para
comprar um pão da água não brincava em
dinheiro ajudará muita coisa mas nós que
importa agora o valor da nota mas sim o
que a nota tem por dentro dela olha aí
tem muita textura e hoje eu tinha que
estava não estará a 9 para o menor nós
vamos também vira olha aí uma moeda
vamos também ver um cotonete conselho do
treinador é mesmo isso é só vejam só
escutar ele estava em sua jovem neymar é
o mais coisas envolvidas
também envolver talvez um laser qual
será a luz do laser no microscópio da
comexim células como é que vai ver luz
do microscópio pessoal eu vou fazer ser
possível ver luz do microscópio portanto
fiquei pê gayva cip pouquinho bastão
como até e para assimilar bola só nota
de 20 euros em 321 vai meu é uma quinta
azul bancada bem marcadas foi de 1 sopa
tudo muito bem foi desenhado é quase
impossível de falsificar notas e é por
isso mesmo porque tem muitos patrões têm
muita coisa aqui dentro tem muita
informação ok só vou tentar observar
este evento e que é vero embora lá 321
vai embora isso é muito lindo esse verde
é brilhante está aqui até parece um
pouco aquela cara passa dos carvalhos
sabe eu acho que já me inscrevi com essa
textura eu acho eu acho meu tá muito
perfeita
olha é isso seja deve ser muito difícil
falsificar notas
pioneiro é tudo muito perfeito até duas
tramas bem pequenas então prefeita aqui
ok só vou tentar ver agora este bloqueio
é brilhante este é o mais bonito eu acho
quem é pedro léon resenha melhor ok vou
tentar aqui andar mais pela nota e vamos
ver o que é que encontramos o quinta
azul em que estes padrões porque 16 88
tem 15 têm outro padrão aqui a maré o
banho bonito vamos tentar ver se
encontramos aqui alguma mensagem escrita
ou uma bolinha outro bolinha outra o
muita linda por lá então ver pessoal é
coisa que deve ser mais suja ainda que é
uma moeda de ouro na semana a moeda em
32 o valério é e muito ruim pode alugar
microscópica lançou ao vazio só comprar
nossa moeda tem muitas ganhou eles têm
muita coisa e eu apareço lá dentro está
preta está completamente preta está
muito sujo que você está vendo aqui do
lado
só podem ver actuar também talentos vão
só taxa de falha está tudo se fala eu
vou tentar barrar a moeda ai essa união
europeia e os países grandes continentes
é uma grana planeta só um punhado de
palavra europa lei europa muito nítido
tá muito nítido mesmo para está muito
focado da prova e tudo quando estrelas
bloom lucro e esta porta que está bem
suja a lei estava em seja qualquer
pessoa mas eu acho que esse novo paraná
ainda
o eta é única coisa que não tem pelo
notw não é eu acho que a moeda única
coisa que consegue ficar parado pelo
toque pessoal para marcar a moeda vamos
ver outra coisa e esta vai ser a ingente
a pessoa olha só vamos ver o cotonete
surge com cera do ouvido e face muito
jeito sério o que agora ficou sem
bateria mas aqui temos a tv e sexual fez
um só quantidade será que eu tenho
ouvido olha isso olha só quem tem muito
peso no cotolengo comigo nesse ponto no
ouvido só a moeda que existam pelo uol
acho que tem um pouco de batata frita
bqb batata frita no cotonete os
conselhos ou eu sou assim
olha só que ainda rondam 2 e que com
pelo ec né
na quinta feira o ataque e se vão sentar
agora a partir do cotolengo acho que é
muito empolgante assim mesmo vamos
tentar ver se encontramos alguma coisa
olha sob sua meu deus é que vamos
encontrar um plástico totalmente branco
sem exigir nada
a lei é um instrumento muito grande de
plástico mas não tem nada não tem nada
aí outros têm algo não muito em ser mãe
terceira do alvinópolis
ontem mais pilão e é muito nojento só
você sabe que vai ter de fazer história
é como esse contra a itália ó quanto o
carro é quase certo que nem eu e agora
até fiquei muito jeito a pf ele foi
observar outra coisa pessoal velas na
área da cheia de talento só vamos tentar
aqui observar o meu lei 005 tanto ano
agora também não só vocês gostam de 22 a
26 em um vídeo por onde passei mas não
viram e ontem também postou um vídeo
para ter um copo como vós portanto a seu
aspecto de milton e para lá só então
observar que o nosso laser em que além
do bahia então eu vou tentar ser humano
em três um pai olha só tento luisa quem
não dá pra ver fed espera só pensa é por
esta o entra-e-sai que o laser muito
tempo tentar apontar aquilo vai ser uma
sombra preta e vamos tentar observar a
parte em que o estatuto car na zona
preta
vou usar aqui e vou apontar o laser por
lá e vou tentar acertar com câmera do
microscópio no segundo você vai acertar
isso assim muita gente que agora 321 vai
só estão laser
é o exemplo do carnaporto preta está sem
fumaça já tá sem fumaça eu não sei se
vou conseguir apanhar um microscópio
não por ser mais tempo mas olhei nós
conseguimos virar pato um treinador
eu acabei de queimar o meu tempo coisa
eu nunca tinha feito isso nunca tinha
acontecido
eu nunca nem queimar o meu dedo como o
laser ou nem isso que o meu
olha aí eu não sei se conseguem ver que
não vai ficar mas que o momento atual
não tem dessas coisas em casa seria
muito perigoso
apesar de ser muito simples o que eu vou
fazer às vezes nós podemos magoar muito
a sério então desde que seja está tudo
bem agora vocês não têm em casa
bora lá então pessoal a parte mais f
cada deste vídeo não façam isso em casa
especialmente se tiverem uma aranha com
ea casa extremamente venenosa e com
dengue tipo 1 cêntimo e que vive na
amazônia mas não estou a viver num dos
quatro anós aranha ataque e vamos
mostrar como ela está
olhei meu ela quer seguir pessoal ela
está aqui mesmo na pontinha pois não só
a casa dela a casa dela está muito mais
simples é que tirar toda a folhagem
abstenção tudo que tem aqui dentro
porque ela não comia e ela não come
porque as baratas toda escondiam sem
três folhas e ela não conseguiu encontrá
los então ela assim como muito melhor e
ela vai ficar assim uns tempos locais
mas depois volta a procurar e agora ela
está muito bem de saúde que também é
isso que interessa e agora vou tentar
abrir aqui e vamos ver como é que ela
está aqui perto sim e golias golias
está tudo bem é só vou tentar tocar nela
eu acho que é um bocado arriscado mas
vamos tentar ea negou-lhe estão na linha
está muito [ __ ] hoje o meu deus
calma golias tudo em casa mas não vai
embora luís não vai embora
vem cá eu quero fazer um experimento com
que vem cá com puderam ver ela está
muito calma eu já consegui tocar um
pouco nela a outra coisa para quem
pergunta qual é o nome que eu dei a
minha tranquilo eu ainda não vou voar
neste vídeo voar no vídeo em que o
construir a nova casa dela porque eu vou
fazer um vídeo estragos como é que o
alimento e eu quero mostrar como é que
ela como é que é o tipo de mágoa uma
barata eu acho que o volume estava com o
meu primeiro retinha portanto quero
demonstrar lhes nessa altura sim vou
dizer o nome dela portanto espera e
guarani é claro mas para lá então pelo
microscópio adotar e da minha mãe está
aqui do lado e eu vou tentar observar
agora com um microscópio eu acho que é
um bairro inteiro ela vai manter alto só
eu estava que vocês pudessem beber
faltou na minha cama tá tudo bem do meia
está tudo bem eu acho que ela não
conhece pelo nome do disco que já tem o
nome eu trago o meu nome que eu saí mas
não posso voar então ela não quiser que
eu vou falar com ela
só temos o equilíbrio rabo dela o vôlei
tem muito pelo unaids incrível
vamos tentar observar aqui um pouco as
patadas porque isto é o rabo dela tá
cheio de pelo vejam só a quantidade pelo
tem lei esta é parte do tronco só tá
muito focado agora isto é o tronco e se
o trombo que isso é uma parte dela é uma
entrada da pata olhei só vi nos olhos
delas é muito que o tema é muito fofa
mas é um deslinde e bucal e um pouco
tempo dez vezes maior do que os olhos
a lei é muito linda o craque só
conseguimos ver as patas mesmo eu não
fui convidada mas só eu não vai cuidar
mais da minha tranquila eu vou deixá lo
em paz porque ela está muito estando
agora a idade dá pra ver isso só como
podem ver e ela está muito incluída
agora porque ela está cheia de medo
então eu não vou fazer mais nada eu só
quero que ela fique bem opa
muito obrigado golias por ter
participado e agora pode descansar a
vontade está tudo bem e eu por acaso tem
que substituir a água dela está muito
suja já e só espero que vocês tenham
gostado aqui deste vídeo como tem mais
coisas que quero fazer no microscópio e
extensão uva e um vídeo em que diz que
comprar um microscópio de 10.000 vezes
vocês só para ficar e não 600 cara não
faz idéia e e só deixou os mega leque no
espírito não foi inscrito no canal
inscrevam-se ieiss fique 6 até a próxima
de classe